you are out of your bloody mind to leave
him clear-cut you are out of your bloody
mind you know why
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
so we want to move on to marriage now
inshallah and you have one wife I assume
I have the right to remain silent
anything I say will be used against me
and it was it Court of Defense
yeah I will I will I will pass my
solicitor said say no comment
with this
oh no that's ishan yeah uh thing to be
honest with these matters I'll be honest
with you sometimes I joke about this
sometimes I talk heavily about this
issue as well
um jokes aside it's a very it's a
serious Topic in that sense it's it's of
course we can joke around it and and I
believe it's like I've said this as well
like I mean if I mean you probably know
you're I believe like I don't know if
you've had a discussion with your
husband yeah we talk about it all the
time exactly exactly so you talk about
it in what sense though do you talk
about it in the sense of exploring the
idea or just him and within his nature
how does the discussions revolve if you
don't mind me asking you don't need to
it's a private discussion you don't need
to
we joke about it you know it's a joke
but if he said to me before we got
married is something that he wanted to
do I would then think okay seriously
let's have this discussion but it was
never a conversation and he's always
known from me but it's not something
that I personally could do okay previous
discussion then we have to have the
discussion but I do think for a man if
you want to get married multiple times
it's something that you should air to
the wife before you make her your wife
it's only fair but you know everybody
eats to their own
okay
is your husband watching this
she might be here okay
now me sister let me tell you a bit a
few things about me I'm somebody I like
to deal with uh reality I like to deal
with situations that are
real like in the sense where
I believe there's Disneyland and then
there is the reality I believe in
today's time A lot of people are in
Disneyland like they they really don't
understand now I totally respect I never
look I'll be honest with you if I know a
brother is in his marriage
and I would never ever talk to that guy
and start telling him listen okay never
if like there's one brother he actually
comes to the bitter truth podcast he
even admitted like you know he is
polygamous by Nature every man not a
single man on this Earth can come and
tell me he's not polygamous my nation I
will put him in a lie detector test I'll
pay for it so every man is polygamous by
Nature however that this doesn't mean
I'm gonna go and try to wreck people's
family by saying no no go get a second
wife I'll never do that that's very
challenging immature I will say bro you
can do it no problem keep your happy man
I wouldn't even say if that brother who
is
for example I have never had polygium in
his head like he he he's wide like that
don't get twisted it's an area you can
explore it's wired and believe me if I
was to speak to any woman's husband I
might hit General
and I said to them bro your wife is
totally okay with her totally no problem
at all
not a single man on this planet Earth
will say no I would not every man would
say brother forget two I want three and
four
actually if it's allowed six seven and
eight so the thing is here is that every
man is polygamous by Nature these men
that you speak to they'll say oh you
know if it wasn't for the headache okay
so there's conditions so if there was no
headache headache coming from you the
first wife okay good so if diabetic was
in there you would do it okay so which
tells us what you are prone to do it now
there's one thing that you mentioned
which is very important you said
if
he told me from the beginning
yeah now I'll give an example like an
analysis what we understand sometimes
sisters fall into Haram yeah and when
they fall into Haram imagine and I give
this analogy so people can understand
because the moment a woman says if he
told me that he wants a second wife then
that would have been different well
guess what no woman on this planet Earth
would marry a man that says he wants a
second wife unless he is a man who is of
I don't want to use this red pill high
volume and I'm talking about a man of
taqwa who fears Allah who practices he
provides for his wife he loves his wife
yeah a man who has these resources
because to me a woman is built to be
polygamous built I I'll tell this
outright because if Allah's legislative
something it cannot be that Allah has
told a woman to do something that she
cannot do because Allah says in the
Quran
if I'm not mistaken he does not burden
at all more than he can bear so meaning
that if Allah is legislated a that means
that is plausible to be done so if a
woman has committed Haram and she goes
and tells every Suitor that comes and
proposes and says by the way
would any man want to marry her
no no okay
if a man comes and says I'm planning on
getting a second wife would any woman
marry her
probably not good so El man judges a
Woman by her post and a woman judges a
man by his future meaning if when
citizens come and say but you should
have been honest from the get-go like
argument's sake and I'm not I'm not
watching this on you if your husband was
to come and say I've changed my mind no
no I know we've had these conversations
okay okay okay
mind now you can you can't come and see
to him oh but if you told me from the
beginning
true but it's as good as the woman who
committed Haram she knows that every
time she mentions it she gets rejected
rejected rejected rejected so men as men
I'm telling you I'm telling you outright
our mind if I know that I'm polygamous
by Nature I'm not going to tell my wife
because she's not going to want to marry
me unless like I said before am I I
don't know if I had some I don't know I
was drop dead gorgeous or I don't know
it's I was a millionaire or I had I
don't know I was just a very good
feeling I don't know whatever it may be
that you know woman at hypergamous by
nature and she's like you know what I
don't mind sharing this man argument's
sake yeah so the point is what this is
the reason why men will never admit to
it just the same way a woman will never
admit and what do we say to your sisters
that is a sin yeah that is a sin that's
been committed which you should hide
repent Allah forgive you yeah no problem
so it's a sin can we say a man has a
right to okay man's prayer okay it's for
hard for a man to imagine that somebody
okay okay but here is halal
this is halal
this this is halal here so the point is
what my dear sister and the reason why
I'm emphasizing on this topic is why
because every man is polygamous by
nature and the more we attack and I say
this to sisters who contact me my my
husband wants to get a second wife I'm
gonna divorce my sister just want to ask
you a quick simple question does your
husband pray yeah does he fast yeah does
he uh give him zakah yes is he good to
you yes does he love you yes caring yes
ever hit you this that no
this is a good man you are out of your
bloody mind to leave him clear-cut you
are out of your bloody mind you know why
because you got look my dear sisters who
are watching this
Do Not For a Moment think that the next
man you're going to marry is going to be
any different now I'll give this example
is from actually uh thermodynamics the
second law of Thermodynamics and you're
gonna be thinking Brother Ali what the
hell is this got to do with polygamy the
second law of Thermodynamics is that
energy cannot be created or destroyed
let me give you an example these are my
glasses if I set them on fire they have
changed the form of energy and turned
into something else they haven't gone
away they've just changed form
meaning
the next man you marry is going to
compensate you polygamy and me oh no no
I'm so happy with you okay and next
thing you know you catch him talking to
another girl he's either doing in a
Haram way or he's doing it secretly
behind your back or he is man enough to
come and say you know what this is who I
am this is what I am and I'm not going
to do it behind your back because I want
to be honest with you and I call that
man an honorable man but for those
brothers who also do it secretly some of
them I don't blame it because somebody
sits around a Martin so what I'm saying
is this system this is in our nature
it's in our blood yeah I don't want life
let me tell you something if I started a
company pharmaceutical company and I
said I have this new pill Brothers when
you take this you're not polygamous
anymore I will sell out billions you
know why because a man's thinking Bob I
want to take that I don't want to be
this this innate desire that I have for
another woman I don't want it every
single man on Earth will take it we do
not wake up one day and go how can I
destroy my wife mentally and make no no
no no man wants to do that who loves his
wife but it's in our blood
and one other point I'll mention it's as
good a woman who wants to divorce her
husband because he's polygamous it's as
good as me and your husband saying our
wife's nag Every Woman nags Every Woman
trust me it's like me seeing my wife
said something so deep to me and I'm so
damn hurt yeah but she was just having a
moment she's just women are like that
they are sharp with their tongue
imagine me saying I'm going to divorce
you because you are keep saying things
that you don't mean that's within the
nature well guess what Ali or what's
your husband's name sister if you don't
mind me asking you don't say it
no problem let's let's call him the the
handsome brother Marshall I'm sure he's
a handsome brother yeah the handsome
brother yeah the same he says Brother
Ali he calls me and he says bro I've had
enough of my wife I'm like why he's like
she said something really hurtful
brother guess what so did my wife so did
he shuns well guess what bro if we
divorce our wives do you think the next
woman we're gonna marry is going to be
any damn different
no so how about we stick to our wives
the good woman of course they have their
flaws we have our flaws so the point is
what you are not running away from the
problem as a man I'm not running away
because the next woman I'm gonna marry
she might have another negative quality
which is even worse so the point is what
every man is polygamous by Nature my
dear sister and if one day I'm just
saying it doesn't have to be if if one
day for some reason well if it may be he
wants to explore the idea I say this not
just to you I say to all the sisters do
not make the mistake of destroying your
house and going your separate ways
please please I beg you why because my
dear sister
he doesn't do it because he wants to
hurt you he is created in that manner
now of course there's going to be
jealousy the best of women to walk this
Earth and has smashed plates Allah told
us in the Quran the stuff they did and
some of the scholars even say they're
not even blameworthy because it's just
you know what I'm trying to say yes
we understand and we accept you like
that because as men there's things that
we put up with in the sense of our wives
of menstruation our wives are pregnant
our wives have menopause we as men have
a
urged towards intimacy to a level where
studies say there is no comparison there
was termed in times when we need to
compromise however
the point is what if a man who wants to
do it in an honorable way and I'll give
you sisters this hack for free you don't
need to sign up to my course it's for
free if you do not want your husband to
get a second wife here's my recipe
sprinkle it on the Biryani if you like
yeah let me tell you very simple
you tell him if you ever want to get
married again
you are going to marry that woman not
secretly I'm going to know about it you
are going to give her Mahar you're going
to do a wulima you are going to go speak
to a dad you're going to treat her how
you treat me
and now let's see how many men want to
do that because most men they just want
to do a little secret in the car get
married for a couple of months and
divorce the sister but when you put this
stipulation and that's the reason why
Allah
sent down that's the reason why Allah
sent down uh protocols to do polygamy
why because it protects the woman
because Muslim men do it side chicks
Mistresses and girlfriends Allah says
you are not allowed to use the woman in
that way you want to do it here's the
protocols so now man is looking and
thinking about
Lima speak to the dad another in-laws no
I've changed my mind
I'm trying to say so but if your husband
can do that then
I would say my dear sister whoever you
are wherever you are submit do not break
your house because you know what's going
to happen you're going to destroy
yourself him the kids and everybody ask
Allah the one who's created the heavens
and the Earth to make it easy on you I'm
very sure the one who created the entire
Globe it's not difficult for him to give
you some peace make you understand and
guess what Allah says in the Quran you
might hate something which is good for
you and you might love something which
is bad for you our principles in Islam
is not this Dunya I like what I want no
as a man I have to go to war sister and
guess what which is worse me going to
war and dying and my wife marrying
somebody else or my wife sharing me with
another woman
which one's worse at least I'm in a life
half the time or whatever it may be I'm
still looking providing protected I'm
still there for the kids I'm still the
same alley what is the difference me
when I go to work and I die my wife with
the inheritance that I leave she's going
to be having a happy time with the
holiday with a new husband if she wants
to get married again so do you see when
people come and say oh this is a man's
religion excuse me if it was a man's
religion I am better off doing this as a
non-muslim because there's no rules on
regulations and I can just be with
multiple women No Limits not even four
but Islam had regulated it to four and
put protocols in place so it is done in
the right way to protect the second and
protect the third and protect the fourth
and let me tell you something just
finish on the story I'll give a whole
lecture oh no no it's a passionate topic
of mine and and the reason why it's
passionate is some people think it's
because it benefits me let me tell you
yeah I see marriages breaking down
because of this
I know and I'm saying this because I
don't want to see the breakdown of the
family unit that's the reason why I
started the bitter truth show that's the
reason why I'm not working on a project
behind the scenes but the point is is
that look that Allah has legislated and
I know the story of a brother who was
getting to know a sister for marriage I
know this and I know it is the truth
because I witnessed them
this is the said to him
I
um are you polygamous he said I'll lie
to you if I said I'm not so this was
going back and forth and she said look I
don't trust you I feel you're gonna go
get married again okay he goes and gets
married to somebody else
guess who comes back
yep guess who comes back and guess what
she proposes
I take a marriage isn't that interesting
now you tell me the mind of a woman
isn't it bizarre she doesn't want to
share him as the first wife
but she comes back and says I don't mind
being the second wife do you know why
because a woman is white in that way in
the house and now you might be thinking
me never the point is this
depends who the man is depends it
depends so for a woman Allah has created
the woman in that manner woman a
hypergamous by Nature so they look to
this man who might be I don't know six
foot whatever he's got wealth he's a man
of this is that one sister said I'd
rather spend half the time with a good
man than full time with a waste man
so and only that a woman cannot cater to
two men no way but a woman a man he can
so please don't ruin your marriage over
that and I say to all if your husband
comes sit down I know it's painful it's
this but wallahi and I tell men if you
are willing to go behind your wife's
back and commit Haram you are a coward
so if you are willing to please your
wife over the displeasure of Allah you
are a coward so I would say as long as
you put Allah first Allah will give you
a way out do not ever compromise The
Obedience to Allah at the cost like
Allah says in the Quran to the prophet
sallam why do you make what is halal
Haram on yourself because of your wives
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about Islam every youngster
that memorized the Quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
Good Deeds click the link and donate
what you can and share the video for
even extra reward